this I don't understand the value in the  alternative the [ __ ] is being upset all  the time I'm gonna do for anybody even  if it's like a good reason one could  argue nothing's a good reason to be  upset about money definitely can't be  something people have been upset with  someone I know we do I don't think  that's a good [ __ ] reason to be upset  because you live only one life and like  people can live humbly but we don't want  that should we spend my time being  creative and worrying about money people  should spend more time figuring out what  makes them happy and spend as much time  on that [ __ ] as possible how long did  that take sometimes it takes somebody's  entire life yeah making other people  happy